[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight Donald Trump ducks on the debate
as the seven top Rivals to replace him
make their pitch to begin with the Free
World but can any of them actually top
Trump
scientists begin using AI to search for
extraterrestrial life as experts here on
Earth warn it could be the end of
humanity as we know it well that's one
of the world's biggest brains if we
should be excited or terrified
plus inevitably Cinderella is being
recast as a man send a fella uh probably
be rescued by a princess in a diverse
and Equitable new production of the
passing or just a load of old virtue
signaling flannel full debate whether
this is the dumbest thing to have
happened this week in white world or
maybe just in the last few hours
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening Fernando welcome to Piers Morgan
on Center we start with news of a secret
operation inside the White House which
will strike fear into the hearts of
America's allies and Delight its enemies
and yes I have got that the right way
around it's called operation don't let
Joe Biden fall and it's built as a
critical project too quite literally
prop up the President Biden's blunders
and stumbles have become a crisis for
his re-election campaign with a whopping
75 of Americans now saying it's too old
to leave the country the buy
Administration publicly insists the 80
year old leader is fighting fit and
they've got the receipts to prove it
well sort of he remains of course a keen
cyclist
[Music]
yeah
it's excellent spatial awareness
2 10 12 15 Bob stepping on them
it's black anyway
and he has a great sense of direction of
course
[Applause]
where is he
[Music]
thank you
one thing they can't deny is that Biden
has a problem staying on his feet and
that's the focus of a special program
they've now put together this is why
they're doing it
yes
no matter what their cost 2 10 12 15
boobs stepping on them there's a it's
black anyway
[Music]
well actually also pulls the top
Democrats a terrified Biden will suffer
a bad fool in the run-up to November
selection their new two-pronged strategy
is to both reduce the number of times
Biden Falls over by literally training
him not to fall over and reduce the
opportunities he has to fall over he'll
now board and exit Air Force One through
the lower deck where he'll encounter
fewer steps instead of boarding the
plane like a president he'll board it
for a bit like a suitcase
initial evidence suggests that this may
still be a challenge the report says
that Biden will now wear tennis shoes
wherever possible instead of adult shoes
so he has better grip he's also working
daily with a physical therapist and the
doctors recommended he improves his
balance by conducting
pro-prioceptive maintenance Maneuvers
what those Maneuvers entail is unclear
but what is Crystal Clear is that
they're all designed to desperately
reanimate a president who just doesn't
seem fit for the job physically or
mentally last night seven of the eight
leading Republican presidential
candidates faced off of the second Fox
debate once again the elephant not in
the room was Donald Trump who's light
years ahead in the polls my question is
simply this surely America in the world
can do better than a 77 year old is
facing jail an 80 year old whose
campaign strategy is don't fall over
what drew me to discuss all this is a
Republican strategist and former chair
of the anti-trump Republicans Liz Mayer
the conservative talk radio host
sensation Ben Ferguson I think he wrote
that and the CEO of outkick clay Travis
or welcome to all of your Stellar panel
to debate all things Trump who is of
course the elephant in the room so Liz
let me start with you Trump uh is
basically now calling for all Republican
debates to be canceled without him
there's no point the Republican Party
should save them money invest it all in
going after Biden meanwhile the
president is having a whole plan to try
and keep him on his feet
um I've got to say from this end of the
pond
this all looks a bit ridiculous uh
you've got a guy facing 100 criminal
charges and you've got a bloke in office
who can't barely see or walk straight
what is happening
it's pathetic um I would just like to
say at this moment that I'm British as
well as American and I am leaning really
hard into being a conservative which
given how bad our polling is to really
tell you something
um yeah no it's pathetic we have a
nation of what 350 million people and
this is the best we can do
um I'm just lucky I live in a state that
nobody's going to be contesting so I can
write in whoever I want and feel good
about my vote but generally yeah it's a
complete disaster it's a complete
disaster Ben Ferguson it's a complete
disaster
yeah I I wish you'd stop showing those
videos of Joe Biden because you're about
to get rid of the candidate that I
desperately want to run any Republican
again so if you'll stop doing that and
let's just say he's brilliant let's say
he's competent let's say he is a
vigorous young man just like Ronald
Reagan that would make my life a lot
easier but the reality is Democrats
right now put themselves in a corner if
you look at Joe Biden honestly right the
way that you just did you're you got to
be sitting there going what the hell are
we doing but they're stuck with him and
then you look at Kamala Harris you say
okay well maybe Kamala will calm down
people because they'll say hey if
someone has to take over at least
they'll like the VP the problem is her
approval rating is even worse than Joe
Biden's right now which is at Jimmy
Carter levels so it's a disaster for
them answering Republicans look I think
any Republican Donald Trump DeSantis or
if somebody else comes along I don't
think it's gonna happen based on what I
saw at the debates last last night but
if someone else came along they all want
to run against Joe Biden because there's
no way he can campaign vigorously and I
don't think kovid's Gonna Save him from
doing more debates in the future I think
this guy's a train wreck and they know
it but talking of train wrecks Donald
Trump who is The Runaway favorite now to
win Republican nomination and once all
the debate scrapped and so on he is
facing nearly 100 criminal charges we
are into completely unprecedented
territory here where you could end up
with the Republican nominee being
convicted of some of these charges
before an election potentially even sent
to a prison cell which I suspect would
increase his poll numbers like
everything else has been done legally to
him but how can that be right for
America to have a president sitting in
cell block age
that people aren't worried about it I
mean that's the reality they're not
worried the Republicans
as an American I'm not either because I
think that these charges and if you look
at them they're pretty ridiculous and
egregious you made up charges in Georgia
when the statute of limitations had
already run out for goodness sakes and
when you fight these I don't worry about
it and I think the the American people
showing that they still support in the
Republican primary he's got a 40-point
lead combine everyone else's poll
numbers they don't even add up to even
anywhere close to where Donald Trump is
pulling by himself right now so that's
how little Republicans care about this
they know it's a Witch Hunt they know
it's going after your political opponent
and the way they do them the Banana
Republic and the poll numbers show that
the majority of Americans or Republicans
are smart enough to understand this is
political crap it's Banana Republic crap
it's what they do in Russia and China
and they're not worried about it that's
why still pulling where he is all right
clay Travis you like the scientists I'm
interviewed Rhonda santis is an
impressive character you get stuff done
is his big Mantra he's done a very good
job as governor of Florida no doubt
about it it seems to me
just thought he was the best on the
debate stage last night actually for
what is worth yeah now let's take a
little look at DeSantis in action last
night
I think we have it uh the former
president
um you know he's missing in action
tonight he's had a lot to say about that
he should be here explaining his
comments to try to say that pro-life
protections are somehow a terrible thing
you know the problem Clay is is Right
Trump should be there and I know Chris
Christie called him Donald Duck and
that's fine we all have a good laugh but
if you're Donald Trump you think why do
I have to bother I'm so far ahead of all
of these people why do I have to bother
turning out to I need to be I've got
this in the bag he's right isn't he
well yeah he's right right now so far
and that's why the biggest question
coming out of this debate uh thanks for
having me on Pierce by the way is
everybody else needs to drop out of the
race but potentially Ron DeSantis and
Nikki Haley they need to be able to
fight it out figure out who is the
unquestioned number two and then they
need to have a head-to-head with uh with
Donald Trump and remember as crazy as
the Democrat process was in 2020. what
do they do Joe Biden got smoked in Iowa
he got crushed in New Hampshire he left
before the vote was even taken in New
Hampshire I think he finished fifth and
sixth and then what happened James
Clyburn congressman from South Carolina
said all that matters is beating Donald
Trump Joe Biden is the choice he's our
guy and it was over the Democrats said
we're going to pick the guy that we
believe is the most electable it's old
boring plotting dementia Joe they may
have gotten lucky with covet happening
honestly because that allowed them to
keep Joe Biden in the basement and not
get out and everybody could see how
physically frail and mentally diminished
he was but they made the decision he's
the guy that's most likely to win think
about this Pierce Ron DeSantis or Nikki
Haley running against Joe Biden would be
a unmitigated disaster for Democrats and
I think what's changed here is a lot of
Republicans are so convinced that Joe
Biden is going to lose that they aren't
even focused on the electability angle
as much as they can I think Trump has
half of the electorate right now the
other half is for somebody else right
the problem I think for your guy uh
DeSantis is I think it's a Charisma
issue that most people think he's
competent you know he's done a good job
blah blah blah he just doesn't have
anywhere near Trump's Charisma funny
enough the one with all the Charisma on
the stage last night is Vivek ramaswamy
if you could inject that Charisma into
DeSantis with his experience as governor
and success you probably have a very
very very compelling candidate let's
take a look at the lake
transgenderism especially in kids is a
mental health disorder we have to
acknowledge the truth of that for what
it is and pain on parental rights in
school parents have the right to know
the very people who say that this
increases the risk of suicide are also
the ones saying that parents don't have
the right to know about that increased
risk of suicide and I'm sorry it is not
compassionate to affirm a kid's
confusion that is not compassion that is
cruelty so I will ban genital mutilation
or chemical castration
so I also want to play now the Christie
gag about Donald Duck because it's funny
let's take a look at this
and I want to look at that camera right
now and tell you Donald I know you're
watching you can't help yourself I know
you're watching okay and you're not here
tonight not because of polls and not
because of your indictments you're not
here tonight because you're afraid of
being on the stage and Defending Your
record you're ducking these things and
let me tell you what's going to happen
you keep doing that no one up here is
going to call you Donald Trump anymore
we're going to call you Donald Duck all
right now you see he's quite funny
Christy and he's a bit of an old Bruiser
I like him I've known him a long time
and that was a funny gag if you combine
his humor and kind of pugnacious Style
with vivek's energy and dynamism and
Charisma with the competence of DeSantis
you've got a very very strong candidate
the problem is none of them have the
other two components and Trump in his
own way love him hate him think he's the
worst thing ever all the greatest hits
the sliced bread he has it all and
that's why at the moment he's steaming
ahead yes
I would can I just jump here and make a
couple of questions
I think it's promoting when you take a
look at a lot of these post-debate polls
though what you say about vivex sounds
like it's right but when you look at how
voters are actually responding he's
actually coming off very very negatively
to quite a lot of Republican primary
voters so I'm not sure that you're quite
right about his Charisma I agree with
you that Ron DeSantis does need some
sort of Charisma injection for sure I'm
not sure that him necessarily borrowing
from Chris Christie is the best move
though I actually thought Donald Duck
line fell a little bit flat I thought it
was a little obvious I didn't find it
particularly humorous I also do think
that DeSantis and Christy need to quit
saying that Trump needs to show up at
these debates because one of the really
interesting things and we saw this in
2016 also when Trump skips debates other
people move up and his floor the
absolute minimum that he's gonna get
that actually goes down that happened
after the last debate I bet it's going
to happen after this okay let me all
right let me bring in Ben that does
matter I agree with you
Ben here's the issue seems to me Trump
could well run away with this Republican
nomination it looks like he might but if
he does a lot of Independents have a
problem with Trump and you've got to win
with the independence to become
president and it may be that if Biden
insists on running that the only way the
Democrats win that next election is if
Trump is the opponent because the
anti-trump vote comes out as you know
and The Independents don't like him and
they won't like all the legal stuff that
actually Trump May Steamroller everyone
to get the nomination for the Republican
party and then actually a loser yet
yeah look I I think that there's two
things here with trump it depends on if
he can be a disciplined politician in a
general election and you'll probably
laugh at the idea of him being
disciplined but look he's been pretty
smart recently and I think he's starting
to understand that he's got to be smart
about how he talks for the same reason
that you just said if he talks about the
here and now and he doesn't take those
loaded questions about the past and
relitigating the past and he talks about
gas prices and interest rates in the
economy and securing the border and
building the wall he will destroy Joe
Biden if he is undisciplined and he goes
back and tries to litigate the past and
say I won the last election he gets
bogged down in that you're right there's
a chance that Joe Biden could win but
Joe Biden will not win because he has
the best set of plans for this country
or ideas he is a disaster
he would win because he's not Donald
Trump I want to end by getting all of
you we've also win well I've run out of
time here's what I want to ask all of
you and I need straight answers I want
to have the two names for the two people
that will face off in this presidential
race next year I want to have a name of
a winner as well so Liz you go first
that's tough to say it's really tough to
say right now the polling does suggest
it's going to be Biden and Trump but I
have this sneaking suspicion that
somehow it could end up being somebody
like Brian Kemp versus Gavin newsomer JB
pritzker because I think both of these
guys are so old and decraft well you
can't name you can't name it might die I
need two names and a winner go on Liz
okay well let's go with Newsome and camp
and I think in that uh contest I think
Kemp dusts Newsome and I'm a happy
camper okay
Ben I'm just going to go back to reality
I'll bet you seats at Wimbledon because
it's on my bucket list Piers it's going
to be Trump and Biden and no one else
matters and who wins
I think Donald Trump I think Joe Biden
and what you showed earlier is gonna be
what you're gonna see for the next year
and a half
and by the way it will be far more added
to the greatest hits too clay yeah two
names and a winner
all right I'll give you a fun one I'll
give you a fun one pierce I think it's
going to be Donald Trump I think the
Democrats are going to end up drafting
Michelle Obama wow and I think it's
going to be Trump versus Michelle Obama
wow and Michelle Obama finds her way
into the White House
she would be amazing but I've been to
the Democratic debates get ready she'll
come in at the convention I I actually
clay and I agree on this
I think it's I think she would be great
I actually think she was I think Biden
is going to get so much worse physically
that it's going to be impossible
to find somebody new Michelle Obama
would be formidable I think a really
good candidate I just don't think she'll
ever do it but we're going to leave it
there we'll find out thank you to my
pack I appreciate it and says the next
is either going to save the world or
destroy Humanity depending on who you
are so I've asked one of the people with
the biggest brains in this game in the
world you've all know a Harari the man
they're called the AI philosopher will
be here next with hopefully some answers
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
threat Elon Musk is warned of a
Terminator future artificial
intelligence has been described as the
most apocalyptic terms but at the same
time he's making incredible
breakthroughs in finding genes that
cause disease and transforming IVF for
example so I'll be right to fear AI or
should we celebrate it and can humans
even control it when it's developing so
rapidly philosopher and author yuvan
Noah Harari gave me his uncensored take
Eva great to see you here in the Piers
Morgan uncensored Studio last time I
interviewed you you were with us
remotely and we were cut off in our
Prime in what we thought maybe an AI
attack but this time I can assure you we
won't get cut off
let's start with AI okay because you
you're all over this you in Fortune
Magazine this week described AI as an
alien threat that could wipe us out
instead of coming from outer space it's
coming from California quite chilling
words
do you think that there's a real danger
that if we mishandle artificial
intelligence
it could literally wipe us out yes and
it's not only me many of the experts in
the field including the people who
developed this technology share some of
the same fears
um you know what everybody needs to know
about AI basically it's just two things
it's the first tool in human history
that can make decisions by itself and
that can create ideas by itself you know
atom bombs in the end they empowered us
because they couldn't make decisions how
to use them you needed to make the
decision but AI can decide who to bomb
and can create completely new ideas in
everything from Finance to religion so
that's so it's very interesting because
Professor Stephen Hawking in his last
television interview was with me as it
turned out and I asked him what was the
biggest threat to Mankind and he said
when artificial intelligence learns to
self-design yeah now is what you're
describing
self-design or is that another stage
that's another stage but it's what's the
difference between what you're
describing and self-design it's
basically the same thing once it can
create new ideas it can also create new
ideas about itself about its own design
but we are talking about a power that
escapes our control you know it's one of
the deepest fears of humanity for
thousands of years and now it's it's
actually happening so it could be like a
a version of covid-19 in the sense of it
gets out it gets out of our control it
turned out covid wasn't as deadly as the
plague for example but this could be far
more deadly but it could it could
permeate our life at the same speed yeah
the easiest scenario to imagine is like
somebody giving the AI the task of say
creating this super powerful virus and
the AI just goes along and does it but
it could make it more deadly than a
human being could absolutely can again
combine I don't know Ebola with kovids
and and create something that we are
hardly able to even imagine I mean it
reminds me a little bit I remember when
the first chess computers came out and
they were gigantic like a deep blue and
Gary Kasparov the Russian Grandmaster
beat beat these computers to start with
but very quickly they developed to such
a rate that now it's impossible for any
human being to beat a computer at chess
absolutely I mean in a neural field like
chess I mean it's it's long gone they
are better than us but are you are you
suggesting that in a way what happened
there could be replicated very quickly
yes and and it could lead to our
Extinction if we're not careful in
broader Fields yes it can happen in
again Fields like like Finance Fields
like the job market is under more and
more jobs are going to be changed or
even replaced so let me ask you on jobs
I've got a question for you so I was
thinking about when I knew you were
coming in
I'm thinking about this logically if we
end up with a load of factories around
the world manned by robots by AI
then all those people millions of people
who currently work in factories they're
going to be out of work yeah and they
have no income so they can't buy any
products that the robots are making in
the factories so that economic model
collapses doesn't it or am I being an
idiot no I mean this is one of the
dangers now it's not likely that
there'll be a complete disappearance of
jobs as old jobs disappear new jobs will
emerge if I'm like an accountant or a
lawyer or somebody like that where a lot
of your work is based in the accountancy
case on number crunching in uh if you're
a lawyer a lot of it is case studies you
know existing case studies and
developing law and so on I could quite
easily see how AI will very very quickly
make a lot of those jobs redundant
because they can do it all the pushing
for button any job which is basically
data coming in being analyzed and data
coming out this is the easiest job to uh
to automate by AI definitely what about
people like me broadcasters I mean how
quickly are we going to get to a place
where you could have someone a robot
that looks and sounds like me that has
studied through AI everything I've ever
said on air and I've seen a TED Talk
deep fake of me yeah saying the complete
opposite of what I think it was
terrifying and he can't be long before
someone could be doing this with AI me
yes this we're already there this is why
we have this strike in Hollywood because
they understand these kinds of things
these are no longer science fiction
because I heard because okay let's talk
about that that's really interesting the
Hollywood strikes because AI is at the
center of it and what their fear is if I
understand it correctly is that you
could be a movie star and you sign a
five movie deal with some uh for some
franchise thing and the first two come
out and then you want to get out of your
deal and they say fine but we've got
enough now where we can just use AI to
make the last three without you yes I
mean is it a realistic thing absolutely
if you have enough data on someone
enough footage of how they look how they
move around their voice their their how
they sound
you can create the fakes of that person
hey I can now compose songs like a band
like I think it was Oasis right it
actually did a song AI that was based on
oasis's music catalog and it sounded
like an oasis song yeah and again Human
Society is basically based on trust
between human beings and we are facing
the possibility of millions even
billions of fake humans overrunning our
society leading to the collapse of trust
between people how do we stop this
happening
Ben fake humans ban counterfeit humans
let me try and have some positive to
what you're saying yes which is it's an
awesome power AI in things like medicine
for example we have so many cancers
which have never been solved by a human
brain is it likely in the near to
middling future the AI with these
superpowers will be able to perhaps find
a cure for all cancers for example yes
or at least for some of them and this is
the big promise if there wasn't a
positive potential there would have been
no danger because nobody would have
wanted to develop right Elon Musk and
the others who signed the the thousand
names you signed this thing asking for a
six-month pause it sounds like they were
right yes I think again it's not
necessarily opposed to the development
of AI it's opposed to the deployment
into the public sphere I can talk to you
for hours you're such a smart guy thank
you for coming in although that you have
finding me you've painted a slightly
apocalyptic picture I have to say you
Val so I hope that the world listens
again this is a warning not a prophecy
no I understand we still have the agency
to uh it's in our hands at the moment
but it is in our hands and the problem
with that is I'm not sure I completely
trust our ability to to do what we
should be doing
uh but we'll find out hopefully not the
hard way thank you very much thank you
well that was just a taste of a really
fascinating interview with a highly
intelligent guy who really gets all the
issues about AI Yuval Noah Harari that
whole interview unedited uh there's a
lot more of it it'll be on our
uncensored YouTube channel uh in the
next couple of days uh We've now got
over one and a half million subscribers
so thank you for those who subscribed
and if you haven't yet what's keeping
you so much great content there you just
salivate over including that full
extended interview which is honestly
fascinating and quite alarming but I I
feel comfortable that people like him
are looking into this properly because
we need that kind of smarts to do it on
sense of next the Scottish ballet he
plans to introduce a Twist on the
classic Cinderella Story yeah you
guessed it she'll be played by a bloke
who's rescued by a woman of course of
course I'll debate Cinder fella going to
the balls or whatever it is with the
fact next
foreign
[Music]
Trump yeah look at him fail stop working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks you believe you can win
this war but it's making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application forum and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
let it roll
[Music]
producing oil the knock-on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
I know you're probably going to vote me
off shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
well I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
foreign
I'm joined by my Super PAC first time
these three have been together talk to
Elise International editor Isabell
oakshot talk to your contributor Paula
Ron Adrian and the comedian his words of
mine James Barr welcome to all of you
wow that's a little gag James to get you
in the right Spirit um I want to play a
little tribute before we get to the pack
to one of Britain's greatest ever actors
and I use that phrase very deliberately
so Michael Gambon has died aged 82.
um so many things you could say about
him he just had an amazing career
amazing range he was one of the true
greats that our theater has ever
produced and of course in many great
movies and so on I once interviewed him
at the National Theater
um where he played many a great role and
I asked him what he thought of the
increasing malaise sort of talentless
zedless celebrity wannabes trying to be
stars and he went you know all I've ever
wanted to do was act I remember sitting
in this very dressing room after my
first here and people outside applauding
when they saw me at the window and that
was so exciting it's what I wanted
recognition of my work
there were all these modern celebrities
want is a quick buck with no Talent or
hard work required it's awful
so I said to him what would you call
this type of person
and Sir Michael looked at me and smoked
and said I would call them a
bye Pizza Michael you were brilliant on
stage and you were brilliant off it to
interview
um a great actor
I want to talk about uh another
theatrical story
Cinderfella the Scottish ballet is doing
what everyone does now they're taking a
very popular classic fairy tale which
obviously is about a woman identifying
as a woman
um and they're going to switch around so
apparently audiences won't know
apparently from nights might be very
exciting whether it'll be Cinderella or
Cinderfella uh to which my point is it
was why can't we just leave this stuff
alone why do they won't Brigade have to
come for everything why did that to ruin
everything what's a degender change
gender abuse gender why can't they just
leave us alone these people why can't
Cinderella be Cinderella do you know
something really weird this was actually
first done in the 60s yes there was a
thing called Cinderfella yes a Phil I
think yes this is not a joke no well it
was satire was it but it's not yes so
this isn't even original that I'm going
to actually surprise you and say I
actually think this oh God no you've
gone
we've lost you I wouldn't take my kids
to it you're supposed to be on this pack
as a voice of Common Sense come on it's
quite entertaining I mean yeah it's not
quite like that element of Jeopardy is
it going to be Cinderfella wait a minute
Isabel you wouldn't take your children
I'm joking yeah it's an absolutely like
it's rubbish it's just a tendency James
all right James said I know what you're
gonna say why why are you being bothered
but actually it's a really important
thing because it's flipping the
narrative and making it guys what's the
narrative no it is because it's turning
the guy into the victim who needs saving
yeah and ultimately we all need saving
particularly you right now on this
planet well why don't you love it down
realm where everyone is doing you could
actually play one of the ugly sisters
finally your dream role
you came to play didn't you oh but I'm
not serious though we talk about
masculine toxicity and here we have the
classic example why aren't you
supporting this why don't you want men
to be vulnerable why don't you want
other men
I'm just saying my men being vulnerable
but you know what I love most in the
world I like a stiff up a British I like
people who don't spend their entire time
that's what their entire time
absolutely up to here with the victim
culture that we now have to endure well
everyone's a victim weakness is
celebrated
strength is a problem right everyone has
to be in mode 24 7 to come into work did
you not ask the question is why we ask
the question why why why that sounded
like a victim to me do you know who's
stronger then he's not a victim Mick
Jagger right who's 80 years old uh still
doing his thing amazing uh really
physical free to be still prancing
around doing that I mean look at Joe
Biden by comparison then within about
eight months of age right
um Mick Jagger has announced he's not
going to give his money to his eight
kids he's got apparently 500 million
dollars right I I like that idea if my
kids are watching I really like that
idea because why would he give why would
you give Isabel all that cash to young
people before they've even tried to make
their own way in many of the cases of
his kids some are still very young why
remove all hunger people I know you've
done that too I know people have given
their kids loads of money very bad idea
it kills the hunger yeah and without the
hunger and desire to make that money for
yourself I think you end up with just a
wasted life I completely agree with you
I am going to assume that he's leaving
them something they probably already
have assets whether it's property
whatever but absolutely if you make life
too easy for your children if they don't
actually have to feel a bit of a
struggle then there's nothing to get up
for and then you know they drift around
they flop around yeah I talked to
Cristiano Ronaldo about this right and
we had dinner one night after
interviewed him the first time and he
was saying that you know he is his son's
very good at football the old his oldest
son and he said he's very very good but
he can't give him the hunger that he had
he was literally hungry he used to sit
around the back of a McDonald's and two
lovely ladies he said I wish I could we
tried to find him but we couldn't
um they used to give him the cast off
it's problematic yeah we should give the
cast off Big Macs right and he said that
was how hungry I was so yeah everything
was driven by this intense desire to get
out of that cycle he was in of hunger
but when his son is now got a dad worth
a billion dollars probably right you
can't give that doesn't mean to say he
won't develop his own desire and hunger
it's so much harder to instill it in
someone right I would just say I'd like
to pick up on what you said there
because you were commending Mick Jagger
for jumping around on stage at his age
yes but you wouldn't say that about
Madonna so I didn't know hypocrisy no
because she it's the way she dresses and
the way she humiliates and leading on
from that I'm not actually concerned
whether Mick Jagger would give leave his
children money I mean Jerry Hall Bianca
Jagger I mean these are strong women you
know they are there supporting the
children so this isn't really about Mick
Jagger leaving history it's more about a
principle yeah I do think I've seen
people leave their kids too much money
and they just they just remove any
incentive how much money are you leaving
your kids appears very little right
actually well I say very little I'd like
to think I can help them in some way
right I would like to remove from
everybody right never mind my kids but
anyone's kids right I'd like to remove
the stress of having no money I think
the stress of not being able to feed
yourself or feed your your children or
your family or whatever that is one of
the worst stresses in the world outside
of bad Health right I think this is the
ultimately the problem with this article
because Mick Jagger can sit back and
laugh about how he's not going to leave
he's very comfortable children more
money they don't need it be interesting
to know what he is going to do with it I
don't know whether he's revealed that he
said yeah might give it to Charities
that you might do some good in the world
yeah an lgbtq plus charity oh not enough
hang on what did you call it LGBT
what happened to the two oh goodness me
we're the twos yeah they're there no no
you didn't see two oh leave me alone
where are they why did you say two two
plus two lgbtq I'm really disappointed
with you James thank you I really think
I mean obviously by tomorrow there'll be
another one but at the moment it just it
is Q2 plus so I know that and I'm
surprised we should cancel him maybe
well maybe honestly I thought you caught
the woke mindful as a two-spirit penguin
myself I've identified as a two I'm
actually personally taking that very
badly you're saying you're half black
and half white no I'm a tooth fairy
penguin uh well I think we all are a bit
I have an idea I had my DNA Done Right
zero English Okay zero mainly Irish a
bit of Scottish uh they charted me back
to Robert the Bruce
um a little bit of Welsh a little bit of
Middle Eastern quite a lot right Jenny
but absolutely sorry and a lot of
misogyny
but zero English very interesting yeah
and yeah I was born in England Scottish
would feel about that so I'm thinking
that we're on a work work due to
Scotland to watch the ballet right no
we're not right uh we're going to talk
instead about it's it's calling somebody
woke as bad as a Rachel slur actress
Kathy Tyson said in an interview the
telegraph for me it's as bad a term as
an offensive racial slur the term woke
and race guard are deeply offensive to
me so the latter is thrown in your face
if you make a criticism of anything so
here's the thing James I don't think it
is because I wrote a whole book about
this I identify as woke by the original
definition which came from the American
music business in the 60s and it was
about raising awareness of Social and
racial Injustice I absolutely by that
criteria I'm a woke person right what's
happened is workers become hijacked by a
lot of social media mobs in particular
and they use it as a form of fascism now
to basically try and make everybody
conform to their way of thinking that's
my problem with that see I found that
interesting because I actually think
it's that but also the opposite of that
in that people use it as a slur to say
to undermine your other things become a
slow by definition because the people in
that woke world who identify themselves
well I'm not so sure why you're blaming
woke people for that because a lot of
them I think are actually worthy of
condemnation for propagating the
nonsensical views they have and then
expecting all of us to agree with it you
have actually used the word woke about
me as a slur you've called me a wokie
right exactly so in a way you're that's
because you propagate woke uh thought
processes which are ridiculous so you
think it's ridiculous to like stand for
race stand Against Racism no but if I
ask you for example should biological
males be allowed
because you know what you would have to
say to fit the criteria of being a wokie
you would have to say you agree with it
and in that moment everyone watching at
home goes we're a complete literacy then
you're a woke you're awoky by the common
definition today this is a complete
classic of the genre isn't she because
she's going on about how deeply offended
she is and that is the whole thing about
wokery it's continually about people
being offended offended by everything
causing a fence and everyone everyone
and I mean so should swallow brother men
have been deeply offended by Gary
lineker's tweet I don't think she should
have been but she told us that she was
she told us how outrageous
well I don't think even you think he was
suspended first I don't think he even
you as a black woman can feel
comfortable that calling someone woke is
as bad as a racial slur come on uh it
what the point is and it's a point that
I agree with with James and pick up on
it's use now as a pejorative isn't it
it's used to itself when it's dessert
yeah I don't think it is when it's
deserved I think it's just thrown out
there for anybody who happens to say
hang on a minute is this thing no I
would say 99 of people that I call woke
in a in a derogatory manner deserve it
because they're being ridiculous so it
is a slur you agree
close to being a slur as like a racist
I'm not I'm saying that your views the
woke world's view of life I find
ridiculous right utterly ridiculous
therefore I'm using it as a term a
mockery abusing someone about their skin
color is a completely different and in
my view far more serious thing so why
are you using the word woke why don't
you stop using the woke
and say that what you are saying is
nonsense because it really annoys the
woken yes
you know I've just realized looking at
you sitting in that chair you're the new
Richard tires thank you although I
couldn't think of anybody that sounds
like a less light Richard in the entire
world
that definitely felt like a slur to be
honestly
it's a compliment in about a minute when
you go off there you're going to realize
why Isabel may not see that as a slow
are you aware that no oh right oh tell
me what what have I missed oh they're an
item oh really yeah so you've just said
Isabelle's name all right she's fine but
you know you might feel alone
presented in Mexico's Parliament
recently be real I know exactly the
person to ask the great William Shatner
coming next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
it's a jam-packed hour on the talk
tonight Darlings it is coming up Pink
Floyd front man Roger Waters faces
accusations of repeated anti-Semitism in
a disturbing new documentary and an
undercover investigation reveals
widespread misuse of police body cameras
on the front line and what's your
marriage language mean or a new tick
tock Trend says loved up couple share
their toe curling vernacular that's all
at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back a Mexican UFO Enthusiast
capture the world's imagination earlier
by presenting what he claimed with the
remains are too alien to the Mexican
Parliament some cried hopes many simply
wanted to believe who better to
adjudicate than a man who's met more
fake space aliens and we've had hot
dinners the great William Shatner
starvey unexplained on History Channel
and Netflix joins me would be great to
see you again how are you
oh Peter great to see you and what a
subject matter huh what is perfect
timing with your new series of The
Unexplained here we have what looked
like alien mummies effectively what did
you make of it
well what do you mean see that question
itself what do you mean it looks like
aliens the only reason it looks like an
alien is some guy at uh uh uh at one of
those science fiction movies Drew what
he thought was an alien you know could
conceived of what he thought an alien
would look like and now we have an alien
that looks like what this guy thought of
in his imagination nobody's ever seen it
but it now looks mysteriously like the
thing we saw in that movie
let me ask him he's wonderful do you do
you believe that there are aliens and
we're just not being told about them do
you think governments no listen
appears
there are
in an uncountable
uh galaxies that contain uncountable
Stars which have planets the
circling it there are it is
mathematically impossible for there not
to be life on other planets yes just
impossible I agree life for example here
on life of life here on Earth
looks for the ability to live everywhere
trees are fighting each other for the
sunlight and the and and the animals and
the flowers and the grass and and then
you have humans like let me live life is
as an imperative it can't be that we're
alone you know it can't also be that it
cannot just be carbon based so the
chances of life being in other places is
to me is not even a chance no no we did
a bit of research here one of my one of
my team did a bit of pitch research too
your associations as Captain Kirk with
aliens so you worked with some I mean
it's a bit of a stretch this but Spock
you fought with some I've got a picture
of you fighting a big alien there and
you made you made love to a lot of
aliens in Star Trek like Mata the green
skin so passionate like the green
skinned uh Orion slave girl
yeah except the paint kept coming off on
my costume
would you just
when you go off this Mortal corner I
don't think it's ever going to happen to
you I think you're actually Eternal but
if you ever do do you think you will
encounter other other worlds other than
do you dream that maybe one day you'll
meet these things
now now you're touching on that phrase
the final frontier yeah on my show uh I
think I'm able to to say the name uh uh
because of the strike
um
the final frontier was space but
actually the final frontier's death we
don't know what's it's an unexplained
mystery we don't know what's out there
so I would like to think that as you
draw as apparently the drug guy
um said on his last breath of course
that was his last uh last phrase yeah as
he as he as he took his last breath he
said of course as though he realized he
he saw the logic behind everything I'd
like to think that happens and we know
without being able to communicate it
what everything means because everything
shy of a a few uh unassailable facts
like uh I don't know the fact that
you're still alive and and doing your
program
um everything is changeable everything
changes so
what is out there will it be the same
can you will you know it it's
unexplained and that's the name of the
show I've got 20 seconds left if you
knew you had one day left on this Earth
how would you spend it 20 seconds
I would love to do an interview with
Piers Morgan
can you imagine done agreed I would love
that too I'll let you know
she unexplained on the show The
Unexplained in every way is brilliant
great to see you thank you very much
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
like William Shatner one of my heroes
[Music]
foreign
Trump yeah look at him fail not working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks do you believe you can
win this wall this is making me cry
again they're trying to force you out
yes I feel betrayed keep it
award-winning
Lucy letby will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I obviously wish I'd
never met him Donald Trump has just said
he expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next day can we yes
can we
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
let it roll
hello